[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey what's up team it's your boy Denny
director we are coming to you live here
on the daily Denny with special guest
glowing goddess dear Abbi you're glowing
you got that highlighter down your
blonde admiring this is why we're
running late guys thank you and sticking
around we are live right now of Addison
send us your fan questions in the
comments section below I'm gonna get him
to this iPad she's really stoked and
ready to answer something I know you
guys tweeted some as well I got them
here on his paper but I'm gonna kick
things off because you just got back
from Lollapalooza which was major it's a
huge vessel of course and it was your
first time performing yeah I've never
performed in a festival drew I mean I've
gone to festivals because I love to go
to festivals but I've never been to a
festival and been like a performer there
and it was crazy like the golfcart
treatment you get all the catering you
get access to and all backstage yeah I
mean so waiting on like three hour lines
for our tacos it was it was really sick
it was like such a cool crowd and
everyone in Chicago was just so excited
and like it was it was just was this a
real for you knowing that you had been
there as a fan before now you're like on
the other side of it absolutely yeah it
felt like it was just like it felt kind
of historical in a way I feel like I'm
gonna end up looking back on that and
remembering it is such a monumental
moment and like turning point in my
career
absolutely well you're in the middle I
mean the future is bright because right
now there's a lot of amazing things
happening to you you just wrapped a
sold-out 30 city tour and I know fans
want to know what was your favorite city
to perform at Oh probably gonna have to
say my hometown okay my Island but in
Europe London was amazing Brussels was
so sick I always say that when I speak
in interviews because Brussels was just
like unreal in the sense of that there
was only 200 people there which was the
smallest show on the tour and it was
probably the hypest show so I feel like
with your music you rely on that you
need it right that energy and plus
people been following you around for a
really really long time so vibing with
the crowd is important for you huh yeah
all right well you're currently on the
top 40 Billboard charts for home with
you which is a maze
because it's your first time on the
charts but even equally amazing because
you are the only and I want to get this
right only female independent artists on
the chart I mean what does that mean to
you it's crazy I mean like I said about
like I'm all about changing the way the
industry works and I want to be a role
model for people to be like oh I don't
need a major label to be a big artist
and to have a successful song because I
think a lot of people get discouraged by
not getting signed and not getting
recognition right away but I just want
to show everyone that you could really
do it yourself and it's important to
drive your own ship and it's your career
so you might as well take it I was gonna
say absolutely and I know that you know
a lot of young female artists in the
industry they get pushed this way when
they want to go that way so did you feel
like you just had all the freedom in the
world to create and sing and record
whatever you wanted yeah absolutely I
mean when I first started I was signed
with a major and I loved it of course
because it was super it's a big deal
yeah it's like it's like an honor to get
signed by any label so I was really
excited about it at first and then it
kind of just started like I started
really seeing the true colors of behind
the scenes of the industry and then you
don't really have a say and you're kind
of looked at as like okay Madison beer
is no longer a human being it's like
she's a company and we could just
manipulate it yeah exactly like I'm the
robot right and I just kind of felt like
yeah like you said like I felt like a
robot and I just didn't wasn't into it
I'm like a very big personality I have a
lot to say and I just I felt like I had
more to offer them you're forging your
own path and a badass businesswoman and
her song Amanda from YouTube is saying
she is so Wow with this ponytail I know
they love your pony right you guys are
just joining us we're laughs with this
cutie Madison beer send us your question
guys
okay so anyone who has followed your
career knows that you started out on
YouTube and now you're this
chart-topping singer you know I mean
what has this journey meant to you and
what kind of lessons have you taken away
from it um it's meant so much to me I
mean my fans are everything as as corny
as it sounds it's like they being
independent they control everything they
are the ones who decide what song gets
to be the single they're the ones who
decide what music video gets to be made
and like I just listen to them all the
I mean even when I'm ghosting on Twitter
first three or four days I'm still
looking at every person's tweets and I'm
reading what they have to say and I keep
up on it and I just think it's important
and I love I love my interactions that I
have with them and I really value them
so your friends go so hard for you I
know it's like it's I still don't really
know how to wrap my brain around the
fact that I have people around the world
that like adore me it's crazy and they
want to know wink we expect some new
music and the full album you know the
full album probably won't be out for
another few months just because it's
like probably 20% done at this point
so that means I got a little bit of ways
to go so I don't know I can't give you a
date but the new music is definitely on
its way I'm trying to get a single out
before the album so at least a single or
two before the album and you know you
did tease fans a little bit yesterday on
Instagram story I want to show you guys
this photo it's so amazing I was just
like this is the cutest thing
it's you're literally the hairs on your
arms sticking up because you were
playing some of your new music like is
that in the car
yeah that wasn't I know I was listening
to all my new music and I was like
there's just this one part of this one
song that I have I just like every time
I hear the lyrics I get super happy
because I just like I spend so much I'm
I write poetry in my free time so it's
like when I see one of my poems in a
song and I hear those words it's just I
don't know I get so is it the word that
got you because I want to know like
what's causing the goose it's everything
I just also I'm such a visual person not
like when I listen to a song all I could
do is picture the video me onstage it's
performing it and it just all like it's
overwhelming and it just gets me excited
and just like right like looking forward
to the future well who in the industry
has been the biggest source of support
for you would you say you're independent
but I'm sure you have a lot of
influences and people you've met along
the way
yeah well of course Justin as somebody
who is like really really been
throughout my entire career has been so
helpful and so sweet and like a big
brother to me so definitely him I mean
honestly it's like sounds kind of weird
but um pretty much everyone like I've
met almost every pop star except for
Rihanna
cuz we would all know if I met Rihanna
but everyone but Rihanna like has and
they've all given me some sort of advice
like Ariana's so she's like been so
amazing yeah and it's not only about me
she'll like talk to me whenever I'm
feeling down about anything and like I
just it's really nice to see it like
these these artists that I look up to
and so many ways for people like re
because she's a girl's girl she's really
like there to support that's right right
what's the biggest piece of advice that
Ari gave you well it was actually kind
of recently because I was like going
through some stuff on social media where
I was super upset and I was like really
sad and she just kind of saw that and
she reached out to me and she was like
hey like I said seeing her tweets and
you just sound kind of sad and like
melancholy like what's going on with you
that's crazy that she recognized that
yeah no one I and I read and I told her
kind of everything that's going on and
she had called me like immediately and
when she was just like I don't even
there wasn't even one piece of advice
but it was kind of just her telling me
that you should never pay attention to
the people that don't like you cuz
there's so many people that do she's
like pay attention to them because she's
like I'm so deep into my career at this
point and I still get upset and I still
listen she's like stop listening to it
it's not matters yeah so that was like
super it stuck in my head a lot and I
wish you just just having her there for
you and that kind of like capacity was
just since Justin Bieber's friendship
and support really because of course he
tweeted out a cover of you singing out
of James which is incredible what has
that meant to you that that support
system from Justin it means everything I
mean I was Justin's biggest fan I'll say
and I'll probably have some people argue
that point with me and say that they are
but I was seriously so obsessed with him
and to get recognition from somebody you
admire that much was just such an honor
and his friendship just means everything
to me like I I'm just happy that he's so
healthy and he's doing so well right now
and like it just makes me so happy to
see him well because I've known him for
so many years and I just know his heart
and I know how good of a person he is so
it's just like it definitely makes me
like content in my life when he is happy
and he's healthy because you know it's
very lonely at the top and absolutely
especially the other young age there's a
lot of pressure you know and you get
thrust into this spotlight so quickly
sometimes and you hang on but sometimes
you fall off you know yeah and someone
like him it's like every person that you
meet and every person that wants to be
friends with you kind of have to
question a little bit about their
intentions and that's really difficult I
mean I even deal with that on such a
lower scale but I still deal with it and
I can only imagine how he feels about it
so it's it
good that I you know I'm one of his real
ones honest and you call you I saw that
you congratulated he and Haley on the
engagement called in your family members
I mean you're gonna go to the wedding um
yeah I guess I think so that the
invitations have been set out yet but
I'm assuming I've actually known Haley
long as I'm happy which is funny but
yeah they're both I'm just so happy that
they're happy together because I think
that he really needs her and she seems
like the real deal huh yeah absolutely
like they've they've always been they've
always had such a weird chemistry if
like everyone kind of always knew they
were gonna end up together so it's
really great to see them happy and
healthy and take some fan questions Mel
wants to know can you give any advice as
someone who wants to be an artist my
only piece of advice honestly would just
be don't let anybody tell you what to do
as rude as that might sound it's like
you have to be able to define your
artistry and be yourself because it's so
important there's so many people in the
world you have to like separate yourself
and there's only one version of you so
you have to just make sure that you
really put your stamp on everything and
just always be yourself and don't let
anybody tell you that you can't do this
I can't do that because if it's you and
you like it go ahead well say and never
give up never give up the Hustle is real
like bumps I've had to jump over in the
road there's this entire journey that
I've wanted to just be like you know
what this one's too big I'm just gonna
give up on it have been insane if only
people knew what has gone on behind the
scenes and how many nights I've spent
crying and miserable it's just like it's
all worth it though you know to to see
you guys happy at my shows and whatever
it's just it's all it's all worth I love
that some questions I got from Twitter
there was like a hundred responses to
questions so I obviously guys had to
pick a couple but hopefully it's one of
yours what's your favorite song at the
moment they want to know that's a good
question at the moment whatever people
ask me this they always expect me to say
a new song that just came out but it's
always like oh I like instant crush by
Daft Punk that song came out years ago
but right now I will reach or say get
free by Lana Del Rey is my fave or
groupie love mmm she one of you as a lot
of one of your influences yeah I get
that vibe I could see it dream
collaborations Lana
it would be iconic for me I don't know
of course in my mind I'd be iconic
Rihanna I couldn't even look at so that
would happen like us trying to be in a
studio would end with me in tears me
locking myself in my car
see I feel like you need to hang out
with her outside of the studio first you
mean yeah well there's video of Mia
going around right now or like I cuz I
just went to Lala's we were talking
about I celebrex Orange County who was
one of my also favorite artists and I
was sitting at the edge of the stage
just screaming at him hysterically
crying I was actually crying I love you
so much screaming and people were like
now you see how we feel right here show
this like that's crazy people feel that
way about me because I was literally my
marbles were everywhere dude that's why
music is amazing it like don't lose that
fan girl yeah you can't write when
you're not performing or making music
how do you spend your free time watching
Brecon more or RuPaul's Drag Race yes I
actually just started true detective so
I'm like I'm on that
that's a hard pivot from you know yeah
sharp right turn we're happy with
aquaria taking it I was yeah aquaria was
good Oh like my heart I'm sorry no but I
was happy I think she deserved it I
didn't though think that miss Crocker
deserved to go home as soon as she did
right I loved this cracker miss cracker
puts on a good show I like how she was
always compared to a curry like she's
her own person just to say look like
isn't her fault you know miss cracker
crushed that makeover challenge yeah
with the eyebrows no what can we can you
tie brother me the twin yeah yeah who's
your favorite
I was actually team Eureka I don't mean
from this season from all time Oh Bob
directly like so far bob is so all the
comedy queen he is so good hilarious I
love that's Bianca's mine oh and Bianca
wait I forgot I know are you guys you
guys that's also good choice any if you
weren't seeing you what would your dream
job be um I love crime shows like Law &
Order Criminal Minds true detective I
would love to be in exact area I would
love to work in a field like that yeah
cuz I am a design
like you don't think I'm a detective
with my boyfriend like on his phone and
stuff like that
I actually don't I'm actually not as
crazy as I make myself out to be but my
friend actually I hate when people like
you know when you're in a relationship
and know someone says someone's like
you're crazy that's like the worst thing
in the world to you like that is the
most offensive thing someone to tell you
is you're crazy so my friend was at my
house yesterday and she was like she's
like you're actually crazy then she was
like oh I take that back because you're
gonna behead me if I say that because
she's like you do not appreciate the
crazy words you say but um but no I
don't I don't really look through my
boyfriend style but it's your love
language like what do you like though
what makes you feel loved
you know expecially from your boyfriend
like you mean like my lovely I just love
him like anyone's thoughtful and that's
he'll do something sometimes stuff
that's so thoughtful and not just like
validates love to me and I know that
sounds kind of weird but like a lot of
the stuff I don't why I keep doing that
a lot of the stuff in a relationship
obviously validates it he loves me like
the way he looks at me whatever but it's
just I don't know I'm such a thoughtful
person that if I love someone I'm just
constantly thinking about them and I see
something it reminds me of them at all
I'll buy it for them or you know write
them attacks being like hey it's that
stuff even though it's small it just
means a lot to me all right guys we were
wrapping up here but I got a couple last
questions any plans to act in your
future I would love to yeah I would ever
love someone else was like hump American
Horror Story oh there you go see the
choo choo detective American Horror
Story like you're ready to do some
serious drama yes I love it so we're
also asked if you would ever be down to
design clothes because your fashion
slate I mean done if you guys follow on
Instagram like her looks are on point oh
yeah I mean look thank you would you
design clothes at all I actually did I
came here that clothing line with
misguided and it was really really
awesome I got to design all the clothes
myself with them and their team of
course and
they really let me have so much say
which was cool because sometimes you do
things like that they're like no we know
better so you just do the promoting what
you're good at doing and I'm just like
no not gonna work with a company that
isn't gonna let me do what I want to do
so I've never seen a pattern with that
yeah handle that was that was really
cool and I got to design everything in
the fans overseas have really been
loving it
I actually saw some girl at Lollapalooza
wearing one of the as she pleases craft
tubs and I was like we'll make some tees
and I will wear them on the daily I got
to do that about why I came to talk I'm
obsessed with you there's the best love
your music thank you guys for tuning in
and thank you for your questions we're
gonna wrap it up here
you guys know where to follow Madison on
social media handle it if you're not
following her already cuz she's amazing
I've always wanted to do that well I can
youtube video yeah yeah hey guys that's
her name she she's a blast yeah thank
you for tuning in I'll be back along
with a brand new daily Jennie here on
YouTube and et's Facebook page bye for
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]